hey I'm Tim and welcome to our AP US
history live study session at Khan
Academy so the exam is this Friday May
5th and I would like to take some time
with you over the next hour to talk
through some of the major ideas that
will kind of help you manage the exam so
I am a former US history professor I got
my PhD in US history and then taught at
the college level
for eight years so I've kind of been on
the opposite side of this seeing what
students are like when they come into
college having taken the AP exam now
before this livestream started I looked
through your chats and it seems like a
lot of you are really nervous about the
exam and so I just wanted to share with
you that I have been a reader for the AP
exam I went to Louisville with all the
other teachers about a thousand people
go to read these exams every year and I
met all of the people who grade the
exams we sit together it takes about
eight days everybody reads about 6,000
exams and what I want you to know about
that is that the people who are reading
these exams are your teachers they're
ordinary people who teach history and I
think we have this sense that teachers
are reading these exams and thinking
remember where can I find a place to
take off points and it's completely the
opposite of that the teachers who are
reading these exams are rooting for you
they are giving you every possible
opportunity to score points they're
looking for a chance to give you a point
for anything so just keep in mind when
you're writing these that you're not
writing them for grumpy people who are
looking down on you you are writing them
for your teachers who want you to
succeed and they're going to help you
succeed however they can
all right so that said I first want to
tell you a little bit about some other
resources that we have at Khan Academy
to help you prepare for the exam in case
you want to do a little bit more than
just sit here with me so one of the
first things is that at Khan Academy
we've put together a complete resource
with articles and exercises and videos
from every part of US history
so what's most important about this for
you is that we have practice quizzes for
every period from Native American
societies before contact to the US after
2000 so and see that I actually need to
do a little bit more studying here I've
only gone through seven of these myself
but if you are just wondering how am i
doing is there something that I could do
to do a little bit of extra preparation
to make sure that I've got my ducks in a
row
check out the quizzes and the second
thing is a guide to the US history exam
where I go through some very detailed
examples of how to tackle these
questions so I'm going to do that a
little bit today but if you're hoping to
see some other examples you're wishing
you could do this just a few more times
to feel confident check out our exam
practice section and I will take you
through some more questions on the long
essay the DBQ short answer multiple
choice and hopefully that will help you
get a little bit more confident about
your skills okay so what are we doing
today
here is our preview of coming events so
I'm going to take about an hour talking
with you and I'm going to go pretty much
step-by-step through the exam will first
talk about multiple choice questions
tips and strategies and then short
answer questions and then we'll talk
about the long essay question and
then if we have time I'd like to do a
little primary document analysis and try
to help you use that primary document
analysis to think about how you might
strategize at the DBQ so I want to
encourage you throughout the session to
ask questions that you might have I'm
going to pause in between each of these
sections to answer some questions and
then hopefully we'll leave a little time
at the end to answer any general
questions you might have about the exam
all right sound good okay let's start at
the multiple-choice section so I've got
some practice questions for us here and
these are official practice set
questions from the College Board and all
right so here is a typical
multiple-choice question from the AP
u.s. History exam and what is important
about this is that every single
multiple-choice question will have some
kind of what they call stimulus material
with it and so the stimulus material
might be something like a photograph
like this or a graph a map a set of
quotes so it will be a primary document
that kind of serves as the background
for the question and I think what's
really nice about this is that unlike
the old AP u.s. History exam this one is
not so much just kind of like a laundry
list of facts that you're supposed to
memorize in fact the whole AP u.s.
History exam is designed to kind of
reward you for having a sense of what's
going on in each historical time period
and being able to reason from that so if
you're panicking about how you're
supposed to memorize all the names and
dates and places and important people
from 500 years of history stop panicking
and just
to think about overall themes so some
important overall themes might be like
the Gilded Age that was a time when
there was a lot of wealth inequality and
immigration and maybe industrialization
so if you have that kind of sense of
what the major themes and ideas were
from each time period that's really
going to help you on the exam because
you'll be able to use that intuition for
history to help you answer questions
with reason instead of just memorization
okay so here is our first question and
it's based on this stimulus material of
a photograph and this photograph is by
the journalist Jacob Riis and it's from
the late 19th century okay so that's
pretty much all the information that
they give us now you may have heard of
Jacob Riis before he was I think one of
the first muckraking photographers
muckraker there we go and if you
remember your muckrakers they were the
journalists who tried to expose bad
working conditions or corruption and
industry or politics and he's from the
late 19th century and what is this
photograph telling us well I think if we
just take some time to examine it we can
tell that it's a whole lot of people in
fact if I count there's one two three
four five at least six people this might
be somebody's legs so six or seven
people in a pretty small room and you
can tell the room is pretty dirty and
dingy and it doesn't look like a nice
place to hang out basically alright so
we've we've noticed some things about
our primary documents so let's look at
the questions themselves all right
so I think one thing that is really
important about this exam all the way
through is that you need to read the
questions really carefully because the
questions tell you a lot about what time
period exam for example that you should
be focusing on
so if asks you a question about what
happened in the Great Depression you
want to make sure that you're not
talking about something from the Gilded
Age or the post-war era so especially
make sure that you're in the right time
period but also read to make sure there
aren't any kind of little tricks in the
questions because they can be there all
right so it says conditions like those
shown in the image contributed most
directly to which of the following so
conditions I think that they're talking
about the dirty room dirty overcrowded
room and this is where I would kind of
go through the process of elimination so
let's read each of the answers and
decide whether we think it's a candidate
if it's not we'll cross it out all right
so conditions shown in the image
contributed most directly to which of
the following all right the passage of
laws restricting immigration to the
United States okay I don't know about
that one so I'm going to leave it for
now an increase in progressive reform
activity all right well that is a good
candidate because we remember that Jacob
Riis was a muckraker a decline in
efforts to Americanize immigrants I
don't think that's a good choice
because I don't think there were many
declines and efforts to Americanize
immigrants usually that the melting pot
was the way that people thought about
that and then the weakening of labor
unions such as the American Federation
of Labor right well I assume that these
are working people but it doesn't really
say anything about labor unions so I'm
going to cross that one out
all right so that leaves us with two the
passage of laws restricting immigration
to the United
or an increase in progressive reform
activity well I think the laws are going
to happen but maybe not for a little
while in fact I don't think those happen
until after World War one so I think
that an increase in progressive reform
activity is our best answer here so we
know that these are people who are in
bad conditions and Jacob Riis is
exposing them
he's a muckraker who's trying to improve
things so I think it's a good answer
with be cool all right let's try the
other one the conditions shown in the
image depict which of the following
trends in the late 19th century alright
so we are looking at conditions and also
depicting trends alright so this shows
us what something was like in the time
period all right so the growing gap
between rich and poor alright I think
that is a possible definitely okay the
rise of the settlement house and
populist movements hmm
well the settlement houses we're trying
to make things nicer for immigrants and
the populace I believe were mostly
farmers so I'm going to cross that out
increased corruption in urban politics I
don't think so I don't think we're
looking at anything political here and
then migration of african-americans to
the north in the late 19th century well
I don't think most of the men shown in
this picture or african-americans so I'm
gonna take that one off all right and
that leaves us with the growing gap
between rich and poor I think that's a
good answer to because we can see that
these people are facing a great deal of
poverty and we know that from this time
period there are people kind of working
in factories trying to deal with a
growing wealth gap so I'm going to go
with a all right so how do you feel
about the multiple choice
we do another example of multiple choice
or do you want to move on to the short
answer questions what do you all think
[Music]
alright so I think maybe let's move on
to short answer but I do want to give
you an opportunity to ask any questions
you might have about multiple choice
section anything
all right let's do let's do a short
answer and you might have more questions
about that because I think it is a touch
trickier
okay so here is a typical short answer
question and you'll notice a couple
things about it one is that it has three
parts so in each of these questions
you're going to have a sheet of paper it
will just be kind of the front of one
side of a page and in that you should
answer all three parts here so Part A
Part B and Part C and you should answer
them in complete sentences you don't
have to make it a beautiful paragraph
you can just kind of write a B and C
which I'm going to do but make sure that
in this a B and C you do include full
sentences all right so using the graph
above answer a B and C so it looks like
we have a bar graph that include that is
talking about immigration to the United
States by decade from 1820 to 1859
alright so this is good to know right
because this is before the Civil War and
it's not until after the Civil War that
we're going to get the really big
explosion and immigration that we see
with the new immigrants coming from
Southern and Eastern Europe all right
and it's in millions
all right so pretty pretty good amount
all right so a briefly explain how one
major historical factor contributed to
the change depicted on the graph alright
so it looks like the change depicted on
the graph is that there's a fairly high
trend of increasing immigration I'm not
a mathematician but it looks like the
rate is increasing over time so we need
to talk about one factor that
contributed to an increase in
immigration from the early part of 1800s
to the mid a
1800s we need to explain one specific
historical effect that resulted from the
change and another specifical specific
historical effect all right so we need
one factor and two effects so what I
want to emphasize here is that there are
many right answers to this question you
could come up with probably five or ten
different things that would count is
either a factor or an effect here and
any of those is okay there isn't a
single right answer so I would play to
your strengths if you remember something
about this use it so okay one major
historical factor all right well if you
if you have any ideas feel free to shout
them out in the comments I'm going to
say all right so major factor leading to
increase in immigration before the Civil
War I think there's a big one here that
you probably would know well and I would
say that would be like the Irish potato
famine right so what are some of the
reasons that people are coming to the
United States and larger numbers Irish
potato famine was kind of a call that
like a push factor something that was
pushing people from Europe to come to
the United States there were also
political revolutions right the
revolutions of 1848 that sent a lot of
German immigrants to the United States
so I'm just kind of outlining this here
but remember you want to do this in full
sentences so another thing you might
talk about would be the fact that there
were a lot of jobs to be had right as US
industrial production started to ramp up
there were a lot of opportunities for
people to come from Europe or elsewhere
in the world to work in the United
States so I think that would also be a
good a good answer
all right let's talk about our effects
alright so something that this caused I
think a big one here would be kind of an
increase in anti-immigrant sentiment or
nativist sentiment and if you wanted to
give a specific example you could say
something like the rise of the
know-nothing party right those were a
whole political party that was based on
a nativist sentiment know-nothing party
and then another effect let's see we
could say you know this was one of the
things that led to the early temperance
movement you know there was a sense that
new immigrants to the United States like
the Irish were drinking too much and
that it was important to curb drinking
see anything else that we could talk
about maybe oh I would say how about
divisions between the north and the
south remember this is before the Civil
War so all of the immigrants coming in
to the north who are working in
industrial jobs really change the system
of labor even more starkly to say the
North was industrial and then the South
was based on slave labor so you could
say that this was something that led to
a more divided nation before the Civil
War all right all right so I'm seeing
one question saying what's the
difference between a historical factor
and a historical affect it's a good
question
so I think what they're we're asking
here is a factor it's kind of something
that goes before so something that led
up to an event so what was a factor that
led up or cause something to happen and
then
effect would be something that happened
after the fact I'm seeing another
question that says what wouldn't be a
good example for this this question a
bad example answer I would say one thing
that you might be really tempted to do
here is talk about something after the
Civil War because when you think about
immigration to the United States I think
we tend to focus on that 1880 1920
period when more than a million people
were coming per year so make sure that
if you're talking about immigration you
realize that this is earlier than when
we would think of safe many people
coming from Russia or from Italy all
right other questions about this okay
what's the best option if you can't
think of an answer hmm I would say that
if you're stuck for an answer take a
moment to just kind of brainstorm what's
going on in this time period all right
so we know this is 1820 to 1860 so this
is kind of our we call antebellum period
so it's kind of before the Civil War at
the time that we think of kind of a lot
of US history coming together as a
political force so just say to yourself
okay like what's going on in this time
period and you might say something like
oh yeah wasn't that at the time that
there were lots of like canals and
railroads built right the market
revolution or wasn't that the time with
the women's rights movement or it's
before the Civil War so there's probably
some kind of conflict about slavery
going on in the United States because
there was pretty much always some kind
of conflict going on politically about
slavery so just consider how
this might have contributed to one of
the major themes or important ideas of
the era and then maybe you can find
something that would connect up with
that cool all right so we also have some
just questions about form so do you have
to restate the question in your answer
and how long should the answer be
you do not although sometimes it just
it's just helpful to do that because it
kind of gives you a basis for your
question so it's not required but if
you're nervous and you're just trying to
think about what to write maybe you just
write the answer with the question the
beginning of it and then how long I
would say probably just a sentence or so
for each part so I would say just just
kind of get to the meat of it so you'd
say like for example one major
historical factor that led to an
increase in immigration before the Civil
War was a what were pull fuh were push
factors from Europe for example the
Irish potato famine which made it very
difficult for Irish people to continue
to survive in Ireland so they emigrated
to the United States done I been reading
these I would often sum I would often
find people who wrote an entire page but
never mentioned anything specific and
that was very frustrating because you
knew that they had spent a lot of time
writing but they never mentioned a fact
and so it was hard to give them a point
so throughout this entire exam I think
the best thing you can do for yourself
is mention a specific example and then
explain how it relates explain what it
is and how it relates
all right so that is one short answer
question should we try another short
answer or would you like to move on to
the long essay question
alright I'm seeing that the the
consensus is to move on so let's head to
the long essay question if I can find it
now I'm getting close
okay so this is a typical long essay
question from the exam so let me tell
you a little bit about the timing for
these exams so the first part of the
exam that we just talked about section 1
has the multiple-choice section and the
short answer question questions and for
that you get an hour and 45 minutes and
that's 55 multiple-choice questions and
for short answer questions I'm not sure
if you're allowed to move on to the
short answers right away I honestly
don't know you might have to check that
out but I would say you know budget may
be a minute or so per multiple-choice
question and then move on to the short
answer questions and maybe budget about
five minutes apiece for those see how
that gets you alright so after section
one is section 2 and section 2 is the
essay portion and there's a long essay
question and there's a DBQ and the DBQ
is the document based question I think
you usually do the document based
question first and that section is also
an hour and 45 minutes long they start
out by giving you a 15 minute reading
period just to check out the documents
and the DBQ but it's about the same
amount of time for writing okay so let's
think about the long essay question and
then I will turn to some of your other
questions about periods and just like a
general review okay alright so this is a
long essay question and it says evaluate
the extent to which the ratification of
the 14th and 15th amendments to the
Constitution marked a turning point in
the history of the United States
politics and Society in the development
of your argument
what changed and what stayed the same
from the period immediately before the
amendments to the appear the period
immediately following them alright so
how would we go about answering this
question I think the first thing that I
would do would just be to brainstorm
some things that you can talk about so
off the top of my head I would say all
right so we're talking about the 14th
and 15th amendments and if you recall
the 14th is equal protection under the
law an equal citizenship for
african-american men and then the 15th
amendment was the right to vote for
african-american men
okay so what else what might we talk
about just general facts I would say I
mean since we're already talking about
the 14th and 15th amendments we might
talk about the 13th which was the end of
slavery we might talk about Jim Crow
laws we might talk about the KKK or
Black Codes C we could talk about
Supreme Court cases like Plessy vs.
Ferguson or the Dred Scott case
all right so what I would do then is
just kind of get a sense of what these
all tell me like is there a is there a
theme among these so in case you are
struggling with the time period here
remember the 14th and 15th amendments
were kind of right after the Civil War
so around about like 1870 13th was right
at the end of civil war at 1865 so our
question would be was the granting of
equal citizenship and the vote for
african-american men actually a turning
point or not so much so it seems like
there are some good things to start with
here right there's the end of slavery
there's equal citizenship but then
things kind of start to go pear-shaped
right you have the implementation of Jim
Crow laws Plessy versus Ferguson a court
case that legalized separate but equal
accommodations legalized segregation and
the KKK you had a group that was
dedicated to terrorizing African
Americans and their white allies
terrorizing Republicans in the south so
if I had to say whether they were a
turning point my my feeling would be
that I would want to say that they
marked a turning point kind of on paper
turning point paper but none of these
aspects of civil rights and equal voting
rights were actually protected in real
life so it was on paper but not in
reality
all right so I think that kind of counts
as our thesis statement and then we
might want to talk about politics and
society and we want to talk about what
changed and what stayed the same so
politics and society and remember we're
making this argument that it's a turning
point on paper but not in reality so I
think that's actually a good way of
structuring your essay where you might
talk about what seemed like a turning
point or at least a turning point on
paper was not really a turning point
because none of these statutes were
actually enforced okay so if I started
with an intro I would say let's see see
there's a question about how we should
approach writing an intro that's a good
question
I mean being flowery never hurts right I
would just kind of maybe give some
context to the time period and say you
know there had been 200 years of slavery
in the United States up until this point
and the civil war with things like the
Emancipation Proclamation and the
Thirteenth Amendment seemed as though
they were really important points in
African American citizenship that this
was going to be the time and it really
didn't seem like that early on there
were important moves forward like the
14th amendment and the 15th amendment
but by the end of the 19th century Jim
Crow was the law of the land and a lot
of the
the advances that have been made on
paper had very little tangible meaning
for african-american citizens because
they still experienced relatively little
change in status then before the 14th
and 15th amendment okay so if I wanted
that to be my intro and my thesis
statement then I might write a paragraph
about politics and one about society
where I could say something about how
before the Civil War
so this is our turning point before
civil war decisions like Dred Scott said
that African Americans weren't citizens
at all but the 14th and 15th amendment
were a brief moment where African
Americans had the right to vote African
American men and they had equal
protection under the law but at the end
of Reconstruction when the northern
military forces stopped occupying the
south white Democrats or often known as
the Redeemers or the redemption era
retook political power in the south and
that was kind of the end of the African
American political voice until the civil
rights movement the end of the vote and
then we might talk about Society where
say before the Civil War slavery most
you might talk about slave codes for
example that said it was all right to
kill an enslaved person you know you had
no legal recourse for the murder
of your family member if you were
enslaved so something that said that you
know slaves really had no status in
society and the 14th amendment was a
moment that said all right well you
should have doodoo protection under the
laws should matter if someone murders
you for example but by the late 19th
century you had Lynch law for example
where African Americans who were killed
by white mobs really there there was no
justice for that or the KKK here and you
could even say things like Plessy vs.
Ferguson really showed that African
Americans were still second-class
citizens
because it legalized separate but equal
accommodations so the last thing that
you want to do in these long essays is
what's called synthesis you get a
special point for this and that means
that you kind of draw you draw a
parallel with some other time
in the United States some other time
some other theme something that's a
little outside your essay that you might
say yeah this is relevant and I think a
good example of that here might be
something like the civil rights movement
you could say you know the 14th and 15th
amendments weren't much of a turning
point but you could suggest for example
that the the Montgomery bus boycott was
a real turning point because it showed
that if African Americans organized
together that they could effect change
on the system of Jim Crow so kind of
take something from a different time
period a different idea could even use
something from outside the history of
the United States if you know something
about that and kind of extend your
argument a little bit ok
so yeah and then I would conclude and
you know your conclusion can really just
be a restatement of what you said it
doesn't have to be anything special oh
and the other the only other thing I
should mention is that your thesis
statement really needs to be either in
your introduction or your conclusion so
any you have to put it in one of those
paragraphs and that's just to make it
really obvious to the readers where it
is so that they're not kind of just
looking through your essay wondering is
that a thesis statement in fact you
could probably underline it if you
wanted to and that might that might help
as well okay so I'm seeing one question
about this says is there a specific
formula to follow for the structure of
the essay I wouldn't say that you have
to do it a certain way I think there are
a couple of tried-and-true ways to do
this sort of essay one is your very
standard five paragraph essay where you
would write an intro and a conclusion
and three body paragraphs and each of
those body paragraphs might address
something like differences in politics
differences in society differences in
gender roles for example and then you
conclude you can also do something more
like a four paragraph essay and that
works pretty well if you're kind of
comparing and contrasting something and
so you might do one paragraph where you
compare and contrast something before a
certain time period and one paragraph
where you compare contrast something
after a certain time period so I
wouldn't I wouldn't force yourself to do
the five paragraph essay if that just
doesn't seem like it would work but if
you're just feeling lost and you think
how should I do this five paragraph is a
good place to start okay I see one
question that asks how much does
spelling and grammar and punctuation
matter the answer is not much at all
because this is something that they know
is written off the top
your head it's just supposed to be kind
of a first draft now I will say that if
you spell something so abominably bad
that there's just no way of telling what
what you're saying you're probably not
going to do yourself any favors but you
don't need to write the most beautiful
essay ever here it doesn't need to be a
final draft that you've gone through you
know multiple revisions it really is
supposed to be something that's more or
less written off the top of your head so
it does not need to be beautiful it does
not need to be perfect in fact it's even
okay for you to have some minor errors
as long as those factual errors aren't
you know deeply tied to what your your
essay is all about for example and
another thing that you should know is
that all of the points are scored
independently of each other so even if
you don't do well on the thesis and they
don't want to give you a point for that
that doesn't mean you can't still get
points for all the evidence or synthesis
so it's not like you have to kind of
rack up one to get the other they're all
scored on their own cool all right so
we've got about 20 minutes left I was
thinking we might do a primary source
analysis for a few minutes and I wanted
to do this a little bit in lieu of the
DBQ because the DBQ is just really big
and I think it would take up our entire
hour if we tried to do the DBQ
so I wanted to take a look at a primary
source with you and kind of take you
through how you might analyze a primary
source and that kind of primary source
analysis will be the thing that really
gets you through the DBQ so pardon me um
the DBQ is an essay very similar to the
long essay except that they're going to
provide you with seven primary documents
and you're going to need to work
but one of those into your answer
somehow so what you should do I think as
you go through and you read these
primary documents in preparation for the
DBQ
is analyze each one as you go along and
there's a useful acronym for this and
many of you might have seen this in your
AP class your teacher may have said this
to you and it's called soapstone you
have any soapstone love out there
substyle
okay and this is an acronym that just
kind of helps you remember what you
might look at in a primary document and
so soapstone stands for speaker occasion
I spell that audience purpose subject
and tone soapstone all right so the
primary documents that you read might be
political cartoons they might be maps
they might be quotes from individuals
they could be posters so I was thinking
it might be interesting if we did as our
primary document the Vietnam War
Memorial so I guess it's kind of a
sculpture so if we do this speaker
alright Levesque may be a tough one to
answer we could say that maybe the
speaker here is the architect and if
you're familiar with this at all the
architect was Maya Lin and she was just
I think in her early 20s when she came
up with the design of the Vietnam
Memorial and the occasion was I was
finished in 1982 so it wasn't very long
at all
after the war ended so the occasion I
guess here is to memorialize those who
fought and died in the Vietnam War
so her audience I guess would be people
who came to visit
maybe veterans or folks who had lost
people in the war her purpose again kind
of that memorialization to give people a
place to maybe grieve or feel proud of
the people who had fought in the war and
then the subject is the war the veterans
people who lost their lives and then the
tone I would say its kind of somber
respectful it's even kind of quiet I
really like this this Memorial if you've
never actually been to see this memorial
highly recommend it it's beautiful it's
very long and everything is organized by
year the people who are killed in action
or missing in action and as you can see
here it's also reflective so you can
kind of go and see the names maybe if
someone that you might have lost but
also see yourself reflected in those you
can kind of see here that people also
leave things at the memorial so it has
this sense that you can kind of interact
with it or that maybe it's like a proxy
for getting to talk to your loved one so
if I saw this on a DBQ I would see it
maybe as an example of how people tried
to come to terms with the Vietnam War
which is a very unpopular war might be
an example of some of the controversy
over the war
so you might then use that in an essay
that's about for example I don't know us
the u.s. involvement in overseas battles
against communism
for example and show how that was a very
difficult period coming to terms with
that after the war so for every document
in the DBQ you want to mention something
I guess at least four of the documents
in the DBQ you want to talk about the
the point of view of the author their
purpose for writing the context in which
they wrote and there's one more I'm
trying to remember and and their purpose
the way and their point of view context
audience purpose that's what I'm missing
audience so kind of identify those okay
all right so I've got a bunch of
questions about the DBQ here some people
are asking which period the DBQ will
cover the answer is I don't know usually
the essays will cover more than one
period I believe but neither of them
nothing on the exam will concentrate
exclusively on the period before 1607 or
the period after 1980 because those are
kind of less emphasized periods in u.s.
history just because we don't have quite
as much about them so I think the bulk
of what you'll see on the exam is
material that's after 1607 so start of
Jamestown and before 1980 so end of
Vietnam okay um and I see one question
that says how many documents should we
include in the DBQ and the answer is you
should include six of them they'll be
seven
mints on there and you can include all
but one other things
what should we focus on most when
writing dbq's well I think the thing
that I would say you want to focus on
throughout the exam is using specific
evidence and that means instead of
saying there were some protests before
the American Revolution you might want
to say something like the Boston Tea
Party right so name something specific
and then describe or explain what that
is so you're not just name dropping
Boston Tea Party you're saying that was
an event in 1773 I think possibly 1774
in which a group of the Sons of Liberty
dumped tea in protest of taxes on tea
you don't you don't need to know the
date I'm just hoping that I know that
one dumped tea and then connect it back
up to your thesis connect it up would
say and that shows that there was an
increasing amount of tension between the
colonies and the Crown's so use the
names the specific names of things to
show that you have a command of
important events and people then
actually say what those things are and
then connect them back up to your thesis
and I think if you if you did that
across the exam you'd be very well
placed to do quite well all right
so other things we've got people asking
if there are study guides and there are
at the beginning of this program I
shared some ap review that we have on
Khan Academy it's under the I think it's
just general ap strategies and skills
and there I have more videos where I
talk about how to do these these essays
in detail but I also have a study sheet
there that outlines the major themes
important takeaways from each period so
if you want to go take a look at that I
think that's a really good just overall
sense of what's happening and that's
broken down by themes so things like
American national identity work in
exchange so just kind of like a sense of
what was going on and work in exchange
alright um anything else
what should you focus on memorizing in
this week besides the amendments I
honestly I would go back to the like the
general gist of things and that would
just be to say okay in period two right
this is the 1607 to 1754 just a sense
like yeah there were some colonies
happening and the colonies had different
reasons for being founded different ways
of organizing their societies you might
say
yeah I remember that the the English
were more into trying to have religious
refuge whereas the Spanish for more into
trying to get gold and do that for each
of the periods just break it down into a
few important things that you want to
take away
then stop worrying about memorization
I think anything else okay
tips for document citation I think you
can actually just say like in document
one in the DBQ
you don't need to quote from the
documents at length you might just say
like in document three Barbara
Ehrenreich talks about the importance of
good cancer treatment it was just
something off the top of my head so you
don't need to go into like a full
chicago-style citation or put every
single thing that is included on the
explanation of what that is in the DBQ
and your essay I would just kind of make
a gesture tore it toward the the author
and their subject all right all right
basic fall backs if you don't know
something about a particular period you
know I think there are some large things
that go across American history like
things that are characteristic of
American history perhaps and that might
be you know the United States up until
the about the turn of the 20th century
tended to be isolationist in their
foreign policy so before then you can
pretty much be sure that that was all of
the United States was they were not
interested in Foreign Wars and you can
kind of have a big sense like after
World War Two the United States wanted
to defeat communism so they got into
many wars abroad with the goal of
containing communism so I think they're
yeah there's there's some broad strokes
that carry across time periods and your
instinct there is probably good all
right oh okay can you go over how to get
the contextualization point and that's
on the DBQ I'm assuming
so the contextualization point on the
DBQ is I think similar to what your
introduction might be and that is just
kind of setting the stage for what's
going on so for example the DBQ last
year I believe was about the rise of the
women's rights movement and so you could
kind of set to this stage there I think
it was from 1945 to 1970 so it's after
World War two
so that would be a place where you would
say for example well during World War
Two many women worked in factories and
they had the experience to earn wages
for themselves for the first time they
found that very liberating and then you
know after the war many of them lost
their jobs and white women went back to
the suburbs and many african-american
women and minority women had to go back
to prior occupations that weren't as
well-paid and so over the course of the
1950's more and more discontent bred so
that's it's kind of showing that you
know something about this period and
about this topic outside of just what
the documents tell you all right
anything else general tips for time
management on the exam
I think this is something where practice
helps and knowing yourself a bit helps I
am I think I'm a fast writer myself but
I'm a slow planner so knowing that it's
not going to take me as long to write
something down means that I can spend a
little bit more time planning but you
might find that you're the opposite you
can plan super fast but you know you
want to take some more time to write so
maybe use a little bit about what you
know of your own learning style and then
also you're not going to be on your own
during the exam the Proctor's will tell
you how much time you have left and
they'll also say during the the essay
portion at this point it might be a good
idea to move on to the second essay so
given the amount of experience that they
have in the
I would trust their judgment alright
well I think we're at about the end of
our time here I'm so glad that you took
the time to join me and I'm really
rooting for you on the exam let me know
how it goes and again if you have any
questions or concerns about the AP exam
check out our Khan Academy resources I
read the comments in those all the time
so I will probably answer you if you
leave a comment on any of those articles
or videos and I also wanted to let you
know that we'll be doing another live
stream pretty soon and it will be in a
couple of weeks with our SAT tutor Eric
so we'll be doing a live SAT prep on on
SAT material in just a couple weeks so
thank you again so much good luck on the
exam and let me know how it goes
you